dans le pays les russes continuent de
bombarder l'est dans le don-basse mais
pas que des missiles ont été tirés
jusqu'à le vive la grande ville de
l'ouest on fait le point avec Bastien
Redouan notre envoyé spécial à Kiev
5 missiles au total ce sont abattus sur
la ville de ville 3 sur la station de
pompage de sur des transformateurs
électriques ce qui a coupé
l'alimentation en électricité durant une
grande partie de la nuit dans cette
grande ville de l'ouest de l'Ukraine 250
000 personnes étaient coupées
d'électricité il y a eu pour l'instant
deux blessés on a assez peu de détails
peut-être il y en a t-il eu un petit peu
plus mais pour l'instant les autorités
ont communiqué sur ce chiffre au moins
deux personnes ont été touchées par ces
frappes et ces frappes n'étaient pas les
seuls à toucher l'ouest et le centre de
l'Ukraine durant la journée d'hier chose
assez inhabituelle puisque au cours des
dernières semaines les frappes sur ces
régions c'était calmées même la région
de la transcarpatie qui n'avait pas
encore été touché jusqu'à présent à la
frontière avec l'Ukraine et bien a vu un
missile s'abattre là aussi sur une
infrastructure électrique donc il semble
que la Russie change un petit peu de
stratégie non seulement elle attaque
avec force l'est de l'Ukraine une
offensive qui dure depuis le début du
conflit mais maintenant et bien elle
bombarde le du centre élève et l'ouest
du pays et ces infrastructures
ferroviaires que vous évoquez alors
pourquoi et bien il semblerait que c'est
parce que c'est à travers le train que
transit les armements qui sont envoyés
depuis l'Europe depuis les États-Unis et
les Russes veulent tout simplement les
empêcher d'arriver un petit peu plus
loin en Ukraine notamment à l'Est où ils
permettraient à l'armée ukrainienne de
ce défendre contre l'offensive donc cela
prévoit cela présage d'une d'un petit
changement de stratégie du côté des
Russes changements de stratégie
accompagné par des mouvements à la
frontière biélorus le ministère de la
Défense biélorus a annoncé que des
exercices étaient en cours à proximité
de cette frontière et nos confrères de
l'agence Reuters expliquent avoir vu des
mouvements d'hommes des mouvements de
troupes des mouvements de matériel en
direction de la frontière ukrainienne de
nouveau comme cela avait été le cas il y
a près de deux mois alors cela pourrait
présager bien d'une nouvelle offensive
potentiellement notamment à l'approche
de la date du 9 mai la date des
commémorations de la victoire de l'URSS
sur l'Allemagne qui est extrêmement
importante en Russie et durant laquelle
et bien Vladimir Poutine aura
probablement besoin d'annoncer une
victoire